I'm sorry the air conditioner is broken I can handle the
heat so it's okay I
don't wear clothes when I go to sleep But if this happens, I'll
go to the student council room and study Eh, I'll be
completely naked Eh, I'll
cut it to the minimum
[Music] I
thought it was normal
[Music] It's
normal
Maybe I should have been embarrassed if I
took it off Now that I think about it
as a girl, I'm starting to get embarrassed
Just
don't show me your tattoo It's
okay.
[music]
Miyamura doesn't want to take off his clothes right away in front of people, so I have a body like this, so I can take it
off in front of Toru,
but Ishikawa-kun knows about tattoos.
san, let me ask you clearly
what is it because miyamura isn't that
shy
?
I
should have been embarrassed earlier Okay, let's do it one more time.  I do
n't think I'm unfazed I'm
lying Just a little more than two millimeters from my classmate from middle school the other day
[Applause] I'm really
envious of you
Spring is coming to Miyamura too Oh, how many days have
you attended?  It wasn't enough
CD, you idiot, you always take her with you, haha, it
's a lie to say that it's not her, but I'm fine, but I'm
rude to Mr. Hori.
[Music]
I'm
sorry.  I talked about it when I was in junior high school I
got an email
What is that face Ah,
look at the attached image I'm
curious, please stop it
Stop using honorifics
Confused Miyamura It's the first time I've seen you, you're
really stupid This guy is serious